well pretty exciting to see a young man
in his first yard can you imagine how he
feels in his yankee uniform on the mound
at yankee stadium he throws extremely
hard you get to triple digits has a good
strikeout curveball swing and a miss
99 upstairs two away well michael is
that one of many we'll see his first
major league strikeout 99
cloud castle sends a slider on the
ground 2-0 door making that second
career start at third and it's not going
very well mount castle crash lands into
anthony rizzo good to see ryan up and on
his feet he wants to make sure that
anthony rizzo is okay
both appear to be just fine as mount
castle reaches base satandare hits a
high fly to right not deep in fact judge
comes in
makes the catch and luis heal
has a very good inning no runs one hit
one left and at the end of the half
baltimore nothing yankees are coming
about and here's alexander wells this
will be his third start
15 in the third innings nine walks now
he did not walk a lot of guys in the
minors up here it's been different
rizzo hits a towering fly ball to the
right
anthony santander will wave away cedric
mullins and alexander wells has two outs
on two batted balls popped up again this
time down the right field line santander
comes in he makes the catch and
alexander wells with a scoreless bottom
of the first inning so a good start for
wells and after one orioles and yankees
are scoring the second one we are
scoreless both young pitchers both pitch
very well in the first inning one two is
popped up toward third globe taurus
right near the line makes the catch
so chew down and here is severino the
baltimore catcher at 232 eight home was
28 rbi one two breaking ball strike
three totally fooled him totally so in
the inning one two three so one away
it'll bring joey gallo to the plate
curveball wow a 3-1 change up left on
left bend and then a curveball to get
gal a look alexander wells has his first
strikeout knees buckled from joey gallo
now the 1-1
swung on a little bloop to shallow right
it may dunk in for a basic
though gary sanchez bloops one to
shallow right to start the night with
the base hits always a good thing gary
sanchez beat inside but he keeps his
hands inside well here is glamour torres
labor at 243
six homers and 37 rbi
that one has ripped into right field
it's a base hit and it splits the
outfielders and goes to the wall sanchez
chugging around third they're sending
him home and he will make it without a
throw it's an rbi double [ __ ] labor
torres and the yankees lead one nothing
this is the second baseman pat balaka
hit on the ground a second they lemay
who feels gross the first two-way
hard ground ball toward the middle so
chew down the only base runner against
heel
was that ground ball that hugged the
line a deep third and though dora's
throw was wide but he probably would
have beaten it there is the one two
stroke came out swinging so for the
yankees have they found someone pretty
exciting stuff huh three up and three
down yankees get the lead runner on and
here is le mayhew and that one is lined
into right field it is a base hit it
splits the outfielders and goes to the
scoreboard allen drowning third he's
coming home here's the throw here's the
play he's in there
it's an rbi double for le mayhew and
it's two nothing yanks
line drive a base hit up the middle
lemay who is going to stop at third
mullins throws and the ball hits second
base and it gets away here comes lemayo
he will score
and moving to second is rizzo it's
three-nothing yanks
first and third nobody out
lead 2-0 line is a basic centerville
rizzo scores judge holds it second it's
a base hit and an rbi for giancarlo and
the yankees now take a four nothing lead
ripped to left field that's going to be
in there
and it goes to the wall
judd scores stanton will stop at third
it's an rbi double for sanchez and the
yankees are up five nothing this is
really what we kind of expected in this
series the yankee offense to really get
going so adam pleco will come on to face
clay pretoria's yankees have a five
nothing lead
fly ball right center
tagging is stanton santander with the
catch the throw cut off by mount castle
throws to third and sanchez is in there
it's a sac fly for torres and it's six
nothing yanks
and the orioles have a two out base
runner and that will get austin hayes to
the plate
that shot through the right side a base
hit for hayes
back to back two strike two out hits for
the orioles santander to second and
austin aborted first
the payoff
swung on and a lazy fly ball to left
joey gallo right there to make the catch
and then the enemy no runs two hits two
left three and a half innings to play
six nothing yanks rizzo picked up a
single as last time
served into left field that is going to
dunk in for base hit
had to hold up to see if it came in
and it hit the grass but he could only
advance to third so another hit for
rizzo the 2-2
and that's a cold strike three curveball
paints the inside corner and judges
retired as the second out in the fourth
lame use it third rizzos at first
high fly ball deep right field santon
their back track
see ya
a three-run home run for carlos stanton
and the yankees lead nine nothing
giancarlo no sequoia
rounded to third backhanded by odor sets
and fires
[Applause]
tell you what this is a good play on
both ends and rizzo you talked about the
scoop i mean he makes it look easy these
are tough plays odor gathers himself and
that's not an easy short hop right there
just made it look easy now the 02
struck came out swinging breaking ball
what what a five inning job by heel
three up three down and a four and a
half nine nothing
yanks you really can't ask for anything
else from heal the o2 swing and a miss
overpowered mount castle two away crowds
looking for a strikeout
and the crowd gets it so he ends with a
flourish his sixth strikeout he pitches
six innings of four hit shutout ball
and another major league debut so we'll
see what ridings brings to the party
three two
swing and a miss got him a hundred miles
an hour nice way to break into the big
leagues the o2
swing and a miss another strikeout
there's his first non-fastball and a
beauty bury the snyder and the pitch
swing and a miss
how's that for a debut
what a lift for the yankees these two
pitchers another major league debut
brady kerner
mount castle into center field tailing
away from allen who cannot get there
could be a long way to run here for ryan
mount castle cedric's going to score the
first run yeah drives in his 60th run so
first and third with one up
that one is inside first and down the
right field live torres scores
oh dora is rounding third they're
sending him home the ball is bobbled by
hayes
oh dora will score it's a two-run double
for tyler wayne and the yankees lead
11-1
hit on the ground in the infield and the
thunder burst is in time so give rizzo
an rbi scoring his weight in the anks of
the 12-1 lead
drill deep to right field
going back hayes on the track at the
wall see ya
lucky 13.
yankees up 13-1
[Applause]
pitch is hit on the ground up the middle
odor fields flips the short one onto
first double play what a double play
ball game over yankees win
yankees
win
you